stay on the path and be careful because
if you start to mess around and you
deviate especially if you know that
you're deviating
things are not going to go well for you
and that idea is everywhere and I think
it's right I think the idea is right
because there aren't that many ways of
doing things right and there's a lot of
ways of doing things wrong and if you do
things wrong the consequences of doing
them wrong can be truly catastrophic and
I'm not saying don't have fun
I'm not saying don't sing and dance and
play
enjoy life of course and relish the joy
of life
but I think you have to make sure you
don't dance your life away never stray
from the way I think that's what this is
about all the fun and the singing and
the dancing and all the play it's okay
it's good but all those things can be
distractions because there is a path
there is a way
and you know what that way is you know
what you should be doing
and it's hard to stay on that path
because it is the path of discipline
and discomfort but it is the right path
and you know that and it is that path
that will ultimately lead you to where
you really want to be so that you can
live
and you can die without regrets I think
a lot of times people are trying to find
the path
[Music]
different places and different people
and different influences
but man I think so often that path you
know what the path is and people know
what they're supposed to be doing but
they just don't get on the path and stay
on the path all my belief systems have
collapsed it's like yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you see you
don't want to wind up at the end of your
life and discover that you've lived only
one tenth of it
and the other nine tenths went down the
drain
every day stand guard at the door of
your mind and you decide what goes into
your mental Factory don't let anybody
just dump anything they want to in your
mental Factory because you've got to
live with the results
see opportunity always comes days follow
nights isn't that terrific opportunity
follows difficulty but here's what you
must learn to do underline these two
words in that key phrase take advantage
and I guess it also means even God
himself can only take so much just be on
the lookout of the things that can
destroy all the good you start the war
is on and this evening tomorrow mentally
personally socially economically you got
to make sure you're winning the war and
this is part of it why should you even
bother improving yourself and I think
the answer to that is something like so
you don't suffer anymore stupidly than
you have to and maybe so others don't
have to either it's something like that
you know like there's a real injunction
at the bottom of it it's not some casual
self-help Doctrine it's that if you
don't organize yourself properly you'll
pay for it and in a big way and so will
the people around you and you could say
well I don't care about that but that's
actually not true you actually do care
about that because if you're in pain you
will care about it and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely off the
charts well and if we all got our act
together collectively and stop making
things worse because that's another
thing people do all the time not only do
they not do what they should to make
things better they actively attempt to
make things worse because they're
spiteful or resentful or arrogant or
deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that so
there's this weird dynamic that's part
of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt and the things you do
they're like dropping a stone in a pond
the ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think and so
if you act that way of course the terror
of realizing that is that it actually
starts to matter what you do and you
might say well that's better than living
a meaningless existence it's better for
it to matter but I mean if you really
ask yourself would you be so sure if you
had the choice I can live with no
responsibility whatsoever the price I
pay that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters so that's the payoff and I
actually think that's the motivation the
amount of things that we have zero
control over is very small so many
things if we look at ourselves and say
what could I do better what could I do
different how can I make an adjustment
here that the reason that you're
probably stuck in this Loop continually
is because the things that you're
blaming on other people
take ownership of them get them fixed
take ownership of them and get them
fixed take ownership and make some moves
take ownership and look what you can do
different that's what you have to do
pathway forward is to adopt a motive
being that has some nobility so that you
can tolerate yourself and perhaps even
have some respect for yourself as
someone who's capable of standing up in
the face of that terrible vulnerability
and suffering and that the pathway
forward as far as the existentialists
are concerned is by well certainly by
the avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is if
you take people and I've told you this
and you expose them voluntarily to
things that they are avoiding and are
afraid of you know that they know they
need to overcome in order to meet their
goals their self-defined goals if you
can teach people to stand up in the face
of the things they're afraid of they get
stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by your own definitions
right within the value structure that
you've created to the degree that you've
done that what would you be like well
you know there are remarkable people who
come into the world from time to time
and there are people who do find out
over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they spoke their being forward and
they'd get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that perhaps there's another way
that you could look at the world in a
number another way that you could act in
the world so what it would reflect back
to you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now the key is what
you do about it it's not what happens
it's what you do about it and he said if
you will start that process of change
do something different the next 90 days
than you did the last 90 days like
picking up the books to read
do something different like the new
health
disciplines
relationship with your family whatever
it is doesn't matter how small it is if
you'll start doing different things with
the same circumstances
since we cannot change the circumstances
but we can change ourselves
to have more you simply have to become
more
don't wish it was easier wish you were
better
don't wish for Less Problems wish for
more skills
start working on yourself making these
personal changes if you just go to work
on the right thing not get things out
there to change don't try to change the
seed don't change the soil don't change
the sunshine don't change the rain don't
change the mix of Seasons let the
miracle of everything that's available
work for you and start working on the
inside work on your philosophy work on
your attitude work on your personality
work on your language work on the gift
of communication work on all of your
abilities and if you'll start making
those personal changes I'm telling you
everything will change